hey you guys it's the movie
retrospective time
now this one that we're doing today this
is actually going to be
hopefully i don't know if it's going to
be a bonus one because
if you're on our patreon you will know
that we were supposed to actually do old
boy
this week uh but for some for whatever
reason like as soon as it came up in the
poll
like it wasn't on any streaming services
anymore it used to be on shutter and now
it's
inexplicably gone so i ordered the dvd
but i didn't know if it would
show up in time you know for uh you know
to record so
i was like well let's just back up we'll
do one as a backup just in case
and then if we can you know watch it we
can watch old boy in
a couple weeks yeah i mean i or the
place i ordered from is only like
in jacksonville florida so i was hoping
that it would be quick
but we usually have yeah we usually have
to record these like
you know a few days uh prior so you know
what i mean so i just said well
let's do audrey rose because uh shutter
just added it not too long ago
we just watched it a couple days ago and
it's a movie that i saw
[ __ ] ton of times when i was growing up
i saw the i saw the trailers for this as
a kid like in the theaters and in the
drive-ins i think it was
what year was this again it came out in
1977 27th
yeah it would have been mostly theaters
i think
um and uh i remember
the trailer scaring the [ __ ] out of me
the one i don't know why there was
something like kind of creepy about it
there was something it had the voice
over for it the 77
voice over and you and me being eight
years old i
really didn't know what what they were
talking about you know what i mean
yeah i see what you're saying it's just
a i didn't know what reincarnation was
because that's what this is about you
guys right i just saw some
little girl and just [ __ ] screaming
and doing bad [ __ ] and the [ __ ]
spooky voice over and i was like oh
monster movie [ __ ]
this was coming on the back of damn the
exorcist and stuff so yeah when you
watch this movie
you can it's very plain to see that it's
riding on it's trying to be like the
exorcist and
maybe a little bit like the omen i'm not
sure the omen 1 was out at this time or
not
yeah it was the omen came out in 1976 so
i came out a year before this
of that wave of [ __ ]
the paranormal kind of 70s yeah like
haunted houses possession that was like
all that kind of stuff and so somebody
said well hey you know what there hasn't
been a movie about
um reincarnation and there was evidently
a book out
just like there was with the exorcist
and andy the horror and all that
you know they would go to the books for
inspiration and make it a movie
uh but the thing is those men come on
reincarnation
that's not as scary as [ __ ] demonic
possession well
yeah awning and [ __ ] like that so
you know it's already a little bit of a
stretch they're trying to make this [ __ ]
compete with the exorcist they did a
good job
but still it's reincarnation
yeah and that's the thing it's like this
movie
does have some creepy elements to it and
i remember it creeping me out when i was
a kid i actually read the book
uh the book came out in 1975 the novel
it was written by frank defilitta
who also wrote uh the entity yeah uh
which is based on a true story
this one this one is not so much based
on a specific true story i think that
frankfurt
defolita said that he based it i guess
he was reading a book of
supposedly real reincarnation stories
and he kind of loosely based this story
on a couple of those
so it's sort of sort of supposed to be
based on like some
quote unquote non-fiction that he read
that he wrote
but um you know and the book he also
wrote the
screenplay for this now i read the book
a very long time ago because like i said
i was super into all that like creepy
[ __ ] like i loved haunted house [ __ ] i
loved all the you know poltergeist like
real poltergeist stories and real
reincarnation and
real weird [ __ ] type of stuff so i
pretty much burned through like all i
read and evil horror i read the exorcist
i read this i'm rosemary's baby i read
all that kind of [ __ ]
so i read that i read this when i was
probably a young teenager or a preteen
and it did kind of creep me out the
movie is almost
identical to uh the book
which like i said makes sense because
the same guy like wrote the screenplay
and everything
i think the only thing the book goes
more into is
uh you know one of the characters kind
of like where they learned the
reincarnation
jazz like them going over to india and
all that kind of stuff
which they kind of skate over in the
movie a little bit
you know but um in the book they go a
lot more into it
so this was actually directed by robert
wise now if you don't know who robert
wise is
i'm most familiar with him because he
directed probably one of my favorite
horror movies of all time
the haunting from 1963. he also uh
directed star trek the motion picture
from 1979 and he did some [ __ ] back in
the [ __ ] 50s too he did the day the
earth stood still
uh he did west side story he did the
sound of music so he's had like oscars
and [ __ ] like that
yeah that's another thing is is that one
good thing about this movie is if you
like the exorcist
and you like the omen and those classics
you will like this movie
it's not as scary as the other ones but
it is a high budget well made movie
good cast real good acting it
it's on par with the exorcist and and
the omen
in terms of quality although i don't
know if i'd call because like i said i
remember seeing it a bunch of times when
i was a kid
and i remember it being like really
creepy and scary and stuff and it's not
i don't even know like now like watching
it nowadays as an adult
i don't even know if i would call it a
horror movie exactly
it has some horror elements to it like
supernatural paranormal movie it's a
paranormal supernatural
drama yeah i guess you would call it
yeah um i was actually watching a review
of it earlier
and the guy said um you know the kind of
recent movie the exorcism of emily rose
which was kind of uh
you know very loosely based on what that
was based on annalise macau wasn't it
okay so um where they were kind of where
it was kind of based on the true story
of like they were trying to prove in a
courtroom that this woman was actually
possessed by the devil and not
that she so um that's the weird thing
about so it's kind of like
a similar kind of thing to this it's
very strange because it seems like it
starts out
as sort of like a psychological thriller
drama type of thing
it becomes a court drama and then it
kind of turns into a courtroom drama so
it's like
it's really really odd it is odd it's a
very odd movie
it is odd but like i was saying that you
hate it tonally
in production quality
it was on par with the other greats
you could tell it's not one of the
greats because it just didn't have
them it wasn't quite as compelling as
demonic possession
it's hard to compete with that well the
premise isn't quite as scary
i mean reincarnation i've read like some
stories of i don't believe
in it but i mean i've read some stories
about it i'm like ooh that's creepy you
know what i mean like
in a way that like where you have a kid
and they're saying like creepy [ __ ] like
i
when did i when i died and all of a
sudden okay that's creepy
yeah um so it is like a little bit of a
creepy premise but like you said it's
not as creepy as
yeah the devil they try to really make
it as creepy as the devil though
they do you know what i mean and sky
will what's his name from the elegant
man in it and everything and he helps
what's his name anthony
anthony this was actually a very very
early role for him he's very young at
that yeah so
it he's he kind of brings a certain
amount of gravitas to this movie
he's a young hopkins but he's
that dude was he he's always [ __ ]
playing himself in every [ __ ] movie
you could say he's a great actor
that motherfucker's always playing
himself really i mean he's got two modes
playing himself or he's playing half
electrical
because we're hoping he's not really
hannibal yeah but now
he he's a good actor he's a really good
yeah and he classes up the joint
you know oh yeah that's what that's what
his job is
if you have kind of a second or third
rate move pro
movie going on in terms of budget or
whatever
you can bring in anthony hopkins and
he'll class it up a lot
you know he'll fix it you know don't fix
it yeah
he'll come in here be like you know let
me handle this yeah
give it a smooth over the rough edges
because he gives give them
his credibility sure you know uh he
he'll give a movie credibility and uh
what's kind of cool is when he first
when he first shows up in this movie
they kind of use them a little bit as
like a red herring is just some kind of
[ __ ] pervert stalking this little
girl was we
is this did he have some kind of a
sexual motive you know the parents are
[ __ ] tripping out
and i like that angle because you're not
really sure what the [ __ ] is going on is
this
you know you're seeing a a movie about
reincarnation so because that was in the
trailer and everything
it really is his reincarnated daughter
at least he believes that
you know what i mean but the parents
don't know that they don't believe that
they think the dude's just yeah because
why would you
they think the dude's a perv yeah i mean
i can see this playing out a lot
differently nowadays
you'd get your ass shut off especially
in the south
to be honest i kind of feel like now i'm
kind of intrigued by the premise of
what if because like i said i'm not
worried about spoiling the movie because
it came out in 1977 for christ's sake if
you haven't seen it i'm sorry but you
know what i mean
yeah get with the program but you know
what i mean but the thing about it
so the premise of this movie basically
is that
reincarnation is real it's almost kind
of like trying to convince
you that it's real it's almost kind of
like a polemic in that way
which is a little weird but i'm kind of
now that i'm thinking about it now i'm
kind of intrigued with the premise
of what if the you know the uh
premise of the movie was that
reincarnation wasn't real
but this dude actually really believed
it and then they left it kind of
ambiguous it's like how would you deal
with that
like this one person like really really
believing that your kid was their kid
and all this other kind of stuff like
how that would play out
yeah anthony hopkins got some great
scenes in this movie
about reincarnation where he tells his
story and he educates you
on [ __ ] reincarnation about his
travels
all around the world and then he goes to
india to go [ __ ] study from the great
maharishi's and or whatever you know
what they call them do you remember oh
[ __ ] i can't remember he wasn't
maharishi show me this
but study for these great [ __ ]
spiritual masters who [ __ ]
proved to him you know that yes and it
was almost it almost became like a
little bit of a
documentary about india there for a bit
yeah they had some like kind of stock
footage there
like some funeral buyers and mineral
fires and stuff you know
trying to trip you out about india
because you know if you were just a
regular american
well back then that was very exotic
knowledge oh india now everybody knows
about that
again we got indians live across the
street well that's what i mean like it's
nowadays netflix nowadays everybody
knows what reincarnation is but like in
the 70s
they kind of had to explain everything
paranormal because it was like new to
people i guess
like you know or it was new to like
mainstream audiences i suppose
so all right so let's kind of talk about
the how the story this goes
okay so we have uh a couple
uh very upper middle class uh he's
really really nice
i'm going to say that those [ __ ] were
filthy rich
yeah that man and they lived in
manhattan like that
i was calling but we were both calling
[ __ ] on that well the dude was like
a madison avenue like ad executive which
i guess okay maybe you could do
you could make a lot of money and i
don't think it was quite as expensive in
manhattan i mean it was still expensive
obviously basically he's a man he's he's
manhattan's bro nowadays stevens
nowadays they could probably get 30 mil
for that [ __ ] apartment they lived in
actually that's a real building so you
could actually look up apartments in
there like nowadays and see we could
look it up on zillow or something and
see how much it costs i'm sure it's at
least
that was that was back in that that was
a massive place that [ __ ] was back in
the highly centralized economy where if
you worked for a certain film
work for a certain firm your [ __ ]
your little shyster ass could make a
millions of dollars a year just making
commercial jingles and [ __ ] like that
not anymore nowadays you'd be working on
youtube
yeah but it was like this massive
apartment i don't know if it looks like
this anymore but it had like all one of
the things and it was even kind of a
plot point in the movie was that
it has like all these paintings and [ __ ]
on the ceiling which was real they
didn't add that to the movie but this is
like a real building i can't remember
what the name of it was that's life
pissed me off
but um but yeah so you have this couple
uh and the dude john beck plays the dad
um and marcia mason plays the mom
it was bugging me the whole time because
i know i've seen john beck in other
movies
and i was just like god damn it where
the [ __ ] have i seen him and i looked
and i looked on his imdb and he has like
this massive [ __ ] list
but i couldn't think of anything like
there was nothing on there that i would
have been
so familiar with that i would have
recognized him from so i don't know
he's been like on a ton of tv shows and
[ __ ] and like you know over the years
but anyway so he plays the dad in this
and they uh this couple have a daughter
who's about to turn 11 i think named ivy
and she's played by susan swift
who i think this was her first role she
didn't really go
that much into acting she was in a
couple other things like you know
some tv and movie after this and then
went off and did other [ __ ] yeah and in
this point of the movie the movie's
really feeling a lot like the exorcist
yeah you got the rich couple and they
got the daughter
and then and weird shit's happening yeah
and they're like you know doing family
[ __ ]
and like you know planning her birthday
and all they're all already like man is
this a ripoff of the exorcist
but then the plot thickens the plot
thickets
so yeah very shortly into the movie they
start to notice very creepy bearded
uh anthony hopkins kind of skulking
around
yeah looking and peeking in people's
windows and [ __ ]
well not well he's not
like i said you do that nowadays and
someone's gonna put your face off
because they're like why you've been
hanging out here your kid doesn't even
go here
um get away from here pervert and then
you would have to be like yeah
they'd have to put you on a registry
somewhere yeah but like
but back in 1977 it was they still
thought it was creepy but it wasn't like
call the cops kind of creepy they didn't
call the cops later but they called the
cops after they talked to him
yeah because so the thing is they start
noticing the dude and it's not just him
like hanging out by the school or
whatever he's also like kind of
following all of them around
like he's kind of fallen like you see
the dad like on the bus or the train or
whatever
the subway and you know he looks behind
and there's the [ __ ] dude again he's
like man this [ __ ] dude is everywhere
what the [ __ ]
so finally they they call the cops and
the cops are like well
um you know did he hit you did he do
anything it's like you know he's just
standing on the sidewalk he's not doing
anything against the law you know they
didn't have stalking laws back then in
the 70s in case you didn't uh know that
maybe some states did
yeah i i'll state yeah i do kind of feel
like that's like a newer
kind of [ __ ] though things went in and
out you know those talk shows had a lot
to do with like the
new laws coming around [ __ ] that's true
yeah that's when people started to
really understand what serial killers
were
yeah because really really i mean like i
said people didn't really have a concept
of serial killer until the
70s even though they were obviously
obviously there were serial killers
before that like [ __ ] jack the ripper
and hh homes and [ __ ] like that but
it wasn't in the modern belgium it
wasn't in the modern imagination
yeah it just it wasn't really that much
of a thing i remember first time i heard
about him as a little kid it sounded
like something that was made up
you know what i mean sadly that doesn't
happen you know what i mean
sadly no but i think adults kind of
thought that too like
that that couldn't have happened that
can't happen yeah something like that
yeah
little did we know yeah but yeah so
finally they like i said they go to the
cops and the cops are like [ __ ] man we
can't really do anything there's no law
that says you know dude can't stand on a
public street
so you know if he hits you come back to
us so
finally after all this time this dude's
like skulking around like i said and
then finally he approaches
them and he's like man i you know i need
to talk to you and all this other kind
of [ __ ] now
at first they're reluctant and a lot of
the story too
like a lot of the conflict comes from
marsha mason's character the mom and she
kind of um
janice is her name janice templeton and
uh
she kind of wants to hear the dude out
or at least she kind of wants to know
what the [ __ ] are you doing why you keep
hanging around like watching my kid
whereas bill templeton probably he just
kind of just wants to punch the dude in
the throat and he's like just sick of
hearing about it
but finally they agree because the dude
just will not leave them alone
and they so finally they're like all
right fine we'll meet you at this
restaurant just like please just tell us
what you want
and you know what the [ __ ] so they all
meet at this restaurant
and in this very very long scene
probably a long
longer scene than it needed to be but
anthony hopkins
um says to them that
they say his name's elliot hoover in the
booby but i'm just gonna call him
anthony
he's playing himself is that serious
yeah it's anthony hopkins
so he tells the story he's like
basically um
10 10 11 years ago uh my wife and my
daughter
audrey rose were killed in a horrible
car accident like the car flipped over
and it burned to death which is what
showed it which was one of the first
things
i think that's like the first scene yeah
and then like this little girl like at
the window
bang you know what i mean yeah yeah
before they kind of get into this kind
of right
yeah so he basically explains that
happening
and then he kind of gets into it takes
him a while he's kind of like
beating around a bush a little bit
dancing around the subject or whatever
but basically he's like yeah i've been
all around the world and i went to india
and i studied with this that and the
other person
and i basically went to these psychics
he says that too
which yeah like i said i'm not sure how
good that is for your credibility but
whatever he's like so i had this
four psychic friends networks yeah
before everybody knew that psychics were
[ __ ] yeah it didn't you hadn't been
tarnished yet so like although some
psychics told you since that was like
some serious [ __ ] man it's like
but yeah i'm gonna clean that up though
you're gonna clean that yeah corporate
psychics and [ __ ] you know what i mean
and telepsychics is about like
televangelists
i do believe that there are people that
[ __ ] have
free i've [ __ ] had dreamt true had
precognition
[ __ ] of course poltergeist stuff that
happened so
that's all related to some people would
call psionics
but i think everybody has it to a
certain extent or another sometimes
i don't know if it's necessarily
controllable i think it just kind of
like comes and goes like without any
rhyme or reason
something having to do with the
unconscious it's it's an animal part of
you it's not a rational party it's doing
it
because which leads me to believe that
could be that animals may have
we call it instinct yeah yeah what i
mean it's just like a sharpened instinct
it's kind of how i
how i think of it and like maybe some
people's instinct is sharper than others
yeah who knows what whales are doing i
mean they're communicating across vast
distances but
they're spotting they take over the
world is there no well no i mean
is there something kind of like
telepathy happening yeah
too with those sounds you know is it
are those sounds being converted into a
mental image inside the mind of that
damn
whale like a television signal would
that's some heavy-duty [ __ ] you didn't
think of that did it
well i've thought of similar things to
that so what if it was just like yeah
what if it's just a signal like
like radio yeah and he goes in and he's
seeing an image in his mind
that'd be weird okay getting off the
getting off subject
no not yet but um but yeah so basically
he finally gets around to he's like
these psychics told me
that my daughter audrey rose who kill
who was killed when she was five
is still alive so that was kind of the
big thing where the psychics were
referring to her as if she were alive
and were very surprised when he told her
when he when he told them that she was
dead and they were like no no
she's alive and she lives in new york
city and she lives in this apartment
with
paintings on the ceiling and he said two
separate psychics told me the same thing
and i spent all these years doing all
this research
and i have determined that your daughter
ivy uh
is the reincarnation of my daughter
audrey rose
so basically the rest of the movie is
him
trying to convince the two of them that
ivy is the reincarnation of his daughter
like pointing out you know the [ __ ]
the psychic said pointing out that ivy
was
born like pretty much two minutes after
um audrey rose was killed in the car
accident
and then there's other [ __ ] too like
they kind of go into the parents are
saying that every time
ivy's birthday rolls around um she
starts having night terrors
where it seems that she kind of gets up
and starts sleepwalking and starts
slapping on all the walls and the
windows and starts screaming and
freaking out and they can't
um you know they they can't like get her
to stop doing that and she just like
does it every year and it's getting
worse and worse
now it's so happy they don't really
believe him obviously because they're
just like whatever freaks just like get
the way
the hell away from our kids we're
calling the cops
but as time goes on like because in the
movie ivy's birthday is approaching and
she starts having these night terrors
again
and then something happens where she has
one of those and she's like
running around her room screaming and
she touches a window and it's like
winter outside or whatever
and her hands burn like on this cold
window
which seems to convince the mom okay
there must be some like supernatural
[ __ ] going on here
and another thing too is that when uh
anthony hopkins comes over
and starts calling her audrey rose and
saying daddy's here daddy's here she
calms down like immediately so the mom
becomes convinced
that okay maybe there's something to
this but the dad is
not having it he just doesn't want to
know he's like this big skeptic just
like in all these kind of paranormal
movies you always have to have like the
dude being like no
yeah but then the wife's true believer
from the [ __ ]
from the outset well she doesn't buy it
at first either because i kind of
think she just thinks the dude's a creep
they always see the ghost first
but then i know it's just like every
single episode of haunting
do like you don't know what you saw
women don't know what they see women
don't know how senses work
women don't know how reality works it's
it's true we don't know it
don't know what they're seeing i don't
even know how i like walk around
during the day because
we don't know how anything works i just
like lay around like a [ __ ] slug and
figure it out
but yeah so there's all of this kind of
um conflict about it and it's like
you know anthony hopkins keeps coming
over like every time she has one of
these night terrors and he seems to be
the only one that can fix it
and basically he tells you like the
reason that she's running around the
room like that
and that her hands burned on the window
and stuff is that's what happened to my
daughter like she was trapped in the car
and the car caught fire and she burned
alive
and you know what a witness said that
they saw the little girl like
you know yelling daddy daddy daddy like
on the window like
while she burned to death which is
pretty horrifying
but yeah so so as the time goes on um it
[ __ ] starts to kind of ramp up and at
one point
anthony hopkins makes the perhaps um
rather unfortunate decision he uh he
rents an apartment in the same building
as them
and he straight up kidnaps
ivy like one night after one of her
night terrors he kind of puts her to bed
and then he's like oop
i'm out and he takes her and he takes
her but the stupid thing is like
they they find her like immediately
because they get out of the doorman
they're like oh yeah that dude like
totally rented an apartment here like
just a couple days
ago where he was like setting it up so
they just you know obviously the parents
like just call the cops and they go up
there and
uh you know they're like yeah she's
right here so then they arrest him
obviously because that's kidnapping
and at that point uh it goes into the
uh you know courtroom drama sort of
portion of the film and after that so
basically they're they're arguing the
thing about it that's interesting
is that in the courtroom they're
actually arguing they're not arguing
over whether
anthony hopkins actually believes that
his daughter is the ring is
you know that ivy is the reincarnation
of his daughter um
which seems like that would be much
easier to prove they're actually trying
to prove that she really
is the wrist so they're trying to prove
in a courtroom that reincarnation is
real
yes it's it's the bizarre part of the
movie it is very weird
it's a very strange like tonal shift not
a tonal shift
not a big time one but it is kind of
like
when it happens when it happens now that
you mentioned the movie the entity
i really see a lot of the entities style
yeah same writer
yeah there's a lot of that in here
because the entity was like that too
started off as
them poultry guys raping this woman
yeah and then it ended up shifting very
quickly kind of like into a scientific
thing let's catch this poltergeist
that's right i had totally forgotten
about that yeah yeah let's catch this
poultry guys
they had a damn [ __ ] big freezing
chamber and they even made like yeah
that's right
that's what happened again i know that
was like that was a weird ass movie do
you know that i was thinking about it i
think i read that book too there was a
tonal shift when it went from
paranormal into like science yeah let's
catch the damn
ghost we're gonna have like a frozen
ghost like a ghost sickle freeze it
yeah and this one's kind of like that
it is now that you mention it yeah it
does actually go
kind of from a sort of like creepy
thriller with some paranormal overtones
into like a courtroom drama where it
seems like they're really
scientifically or fringe science
that reincarnation is real yeah so
yeah so basically they're they're just
like you know passionately arguing in
the courtroom that it's like yeah you
know the reincarnation is real
and you know what else is weird is that
i guess it
infers that he's trying to argue that
the child is his
is trying to get custody see this is
what's weird to me
it's like i'm not really it's not really
that clear well he well he was on trial
big for
kidnapping so they were basically just
trying to get him yeah
they were trying to get him off for the
kidnapping charge that's right he wasn't
trying to like you know
get custody basically he told the
parents he's like all i want is to like
be in her life and stuff like that
because she's he's got to have
rights technically yeah because she's
technically my daughter which like i
said if a dude
actually like approached that that's
like pretty scary that's like a crazy
never happened in real life no i know
but i'm just like if that
you know if somebody did come at you
like that it's like you would have that
person in prison like
five [ __ ] seconds but but i feel like
in the movie
they want you to sympathize with him
even though he's creepy because like i
said in the universe of the movie
reincarnation is real
and he's absolutely right that his
daughter has been reincarnated as
ivy templeton the crazy thing about this
though i'm not okay so i'm not super
clear i'm not like an expert on
reincarnation or anything obviously
so i think the whole thing is that
he keeps telling the parents or mostly
the mom because the dad's like [ __ ] you
i'm not listening to you anymore you
think he even punches him in the face at
one point
but he's just kind of like we have to
work together because
um andre rose's soul was taken
too soon or something um and then
now she's trapped in ivy's body
and if we don't do something like
she'll die but then okay but then
i don't i didn't i wasn't real clear on
that but then the weird thing about it
is that in the last part of the movie
like after they do the courtroom stuff
and then the judge and everything
like well let's hypnotize her and then
we'll take her through past life
regression which was a big thing in the
70s
like we'll hypnotize you and then take
you back into your previous lives
because people like a lot of people
believe that stuff
so they do that and then the the
hypnotist guy who's supposed to be like
the
the leader in the field or whatever and
he's like oh i totally know what i'm
doing it's totally safe it's fine you
know the little girl will be totally
fine
and he regresses her back to when she
was audrey rose
and she relives the whole [ __ ]
accident
and she [ __ ] burns to death like or
burns to death or dies of suffocation or
however she died in real life
so she dies in the room like where
they're being hypnotized
because the hypnotist he regresses her
back to when she was audrey rose but he
still keeps calling her ivy to get her
to wake up
and anthony hopkins is out in the
[ __ ] room being like she's not ivy
anymore
call her by her [ __ ] name and the
hypnotist is too dumb to figure that out
so so yeah so um anthony hopkins like
picks up a chair and like busts open the
glass because they're all like in a
you know in another room or whatever but
then it's like too late scientific and
[ __ ] yeah so ivy dies at the end
yeah and then the weird thing about that
is there's this little coda of the movie
right
where the mom marcia mason she's like
writing a letter because i guess anthony
hopkins is [ __ ] up back to india
because he just wants to hang out with
them and we're in the spirit room
yeah and and she is like well you know i
believe you
and like you know our our daughter's
soul is free now
and it's like she's sending she gave
ivy's ashes to him and he's gonna
scatter them in india
so that her soul would be released and
she could find like her next body or
whatever
and i was like oh and now this now this
couple marcia mason and john beck are
going to like go around the world
looking for where their daughter turns
up next it's like that
if that was true that could slowly turn
into a huge [ __ ] for everyone
involved
but i didn't really get why i didn't get
why it was dangerous
for ivy to have andrew because
presumably if audrey rose was killed
and her soul found another body
like pretty much immediately um why
like why wasn't it just all cool you
know what i mean like why would ivy have
died but then ivy died anyway
so i didn't really like when they tried
to hypnotize her so i don't really but
she's free now it probably just needed a
dramatic end to the damn movie
maybe i don't know it just seemed like a
weird i'm like i said i'm not real
up on reincarnation so i didn't really
know
what they were getting at or why like
what would have happened if they hadn't
intervened you know what i'm saying i
don't know
and it did seem like anthony hopkins was
trying to
get custody of the girl because he took
her
i'm not i didn't really take that part
of the movie seriously yeah i mean well
yeah i just took the movie the movie
takes itself very easily i just took it
as kind of like a wannabe
horror movie that ended up being more
like a courtroom drama with some
paranormal stuff in it
yeah and um as far as the mechanisms of
how the reincarnation works what they're
showing is a very pedestrian
concept of how it would work yeah i've
had nde and out-of-body experiences and
stuff and
stewart hameroff will tell you that
there are certain things
within quant certain things about
quantum consciousness
to where reincarnation and
he doesn't quite say reincarnation this
paranormal stuff that you hear about
could be very plausible
that the consciousness you know would
survive survive
the death of the brain because it's
quantum entangled particles
and it could re-inhabit another body all
right
the thing is though is you're you're
you're assuming
that i'm gonna just call it a soul when
a quantum soul
leaves the body that it when it
reincarnates it comes
back down to continue where it left off
in time space
no the uh i guess you would say the
spirit realm is outside of time and
space so
the next life might be in the past
of the last life you know what i'm
talking about so in other words like you
might be reborn
but doesn't necessarily mean you're
reborn as a human and it doesn't
necessarily mean that you're reborn
the next day after you died in the last
life you might be reborn
you know 20 000 bc might be the next
life
yeah because you're restarting you're
re-entering into the damn time space
every time
so you're re-entering time space that
the location and time
that you choose at that time it could be
in the past or present or future
depending
compare you know what i mean in in in
relation to the last life you
you had yeah this one brought with you
this one seems a lot more
straightforward in the sense that
that was one of the things that was that
it's a linear broad yeah that it was
like brought us you know because
because she was born like yeah two
minutes like
after the girl died yeah that doesn't
that that doesn't
jive really with the concept of [ __ ]
but like i said i remember a lot of
reincarnation stories that came out from
the 60s and 70s and it's like
that's folklore well yeah and that's
kind of what this is based on
i will say it's this is also the concept
that you might remember your past life
you can disprove that by saying you
don't remem nobody remembers their past
lives
in pretty much every story and like i
said i don't i don't believe in
reincarnation but it's like every story
i've heard about that where people said
yeah my kids said this weird thing and
they found out that it was a real person
that died like before they were born a
blah blah
but it's like that it always seems to
fade away
once they're over about five years old
yes like they don't remember [ __ ]
anymore this is something this is
okay you now you got me into a good
subject
my dad told me that when i was a little
kid
i would tell stories of me and him on a
tractor falling off the damn tractor
but that didn't happen to me and him it
happened to my dad and his dad
yeah i don't remember that yeah
all right but he said i remembered it at
about five
but the thing is is that that necessary
that's not necessarily supernatural
it could have just been a memory that
was inherited genetically
yeah you know what i mean animals may
animals and insects might inherit some
memory
because they seem to come out and know
[ __ ] without mutton
without much education especially
insects
yeah you know so it might be that humans
might be born with like little
vestigial memories from their ancestors
it i think it might be plausible but
they're written over and erased as you
gain your own experience
yeah yeah i mean because which is why
people why
which is why when you hear people that
come up with that kind of reincarnation
he's sounding [ __ ] it's always when
they're a little kid when they're a
little kid yeah
once they're
a memory that was inherited in some way
we don't understand
that yeah i find that more or it could
be just be
kids saying weird [ __ ] kids staying
weird kids kids they wear [ __ ] all the
time
like they don't mean anything my dad
thought that [ __ ] was weird
he didn't think it would he he thought
it might have been paranormal but then
as time went on he didn't think it's
paranormal
he thought the same thing that i just
said that i had somehow inherited a
memory
yeah that's weird when you think about
it it is but
why animals might do it all the time but
they can't tell us
yeah yeah that's true yeah so
i think that's what it is but yeah so if
you haven't seen this but i remember the
book being really good
um i haven't uh seen it or or haven't
read it in a really long time i think
they
i think there was a um a sequel to the
book
i think that was called for the love of
audrey rose or something like that i
think that came out in 1982.
um also lash i read somewhere
i think it was on bloody disgusting or
something like that one of those horror
blogs
they said in september of 2019
they were talking about doing a remake
of audrey rose
which i thought might be kind of
interesting because like i said you know
it's similar to the exorcism of emily
rose like where it's like
part supernatural [ __ ] part courtroom
drama like we're trying to prove in a
court of law
like a supernatural thing um so you know
if they took it in that angle it might
be interesting it's this is a very
strange
i don't know i have a lot of affection
for this movie because i saw it so many
times on cable when i was growing up
and i really really liked the book um
that i read when i was probably
you know 11 12 years old and um but
i would go into it not
not expecting anything scary not
expecting a horror movie you can see
there's uh
elements of the exorcist in it obviously
there's elements of a lot of
70s paranormal type of stuff in it
because that was like a very big thing
at the time
but it's kind of like more
a drama but also
that's trying to make you believe
reincarnation is real
so it's just this very very odd uh
one thing i will complain about it is a
little bit too long i think there's too
many scenes of
uh ivy freaking out and like yelling and
whacking at windows with their hands and
then anthony hopkins coming over
and settling her down i think they
probably could have done like with one
less of those scenes because it seems
like there's a lot of that and it gets
like repetitive
also i saw like another reviewer say
that the good drinking game in this
would be like every time anthony hopkins
says audrey rose audrey
is like you'd be [ __ ] dead of liver
failure before the end of the movie
but i mean those are like minol minor
quibbles um
the little girl in this a little bit
weird looking um
which you know not her fault but she did
a good job though like acting the acting
and this is good a little bit
overwrought but
kind of the way that it was in a lot of
those 70s kind of movies this does take
itself seriously it is trying to make
you
convince you that reincarnation is real
but it's just a really
interesting time capsule of the time
period i think
if to me like you said it has it's
strange tonally
it is very strange it almost feels like
it almost feels like a movie that would
have been made by a religious cult
that believed in reincarnation a little
bit yeah get you to believe it
it does have a little bit of that to it
and it has a little bit of a because
it almost kind of has a little bit of a
documentary feel to it in a certain spot
at
certain spots and it's almost kind of
like it
likes like they've shoehorned in
some religion into it yeah or
spirituality or more than probably yeah
yeah a certain way yeah it is a little
bit like that i noticed that
yeah okay like eastern versus western
yeah it's almost kind of like it's
almost kind of like a
a movie that scientology would have made
[Laughter]
but you know what i mean about the whole
track not as lame as that though yeah
it works but it was actually a good but
it was a kind of a movie that maybe
scientology would fantasize about making
yeah yeah i mean if they had an eight
yeah
yeah we need a movie that's kind of like
the exorcist but it explains to people
the whole track
and how [ __ ] you know what i mean how
you know you can sign on to a billion
year contract once you see org
you'll be reborn many times and come
back you know what i mean
it will be great and it'll compete with
the exodus so make all kinds of money
and then we'll get a bunch of recruits
it seems like something like that
a little bit it definitely does seem
like i don't i don't know
a lot about frank defilitta as a person
like i said i've read some of his books
he's actually a really good uh writer
you know the entity is very good he
might believe in reincarnation that's
the thing it's
it really does seem to me that he does
believe that it's real or at least he
did when this book was
written and when the screenplay was
written and he's really trying to
convince you it's like you know all this
uh you know western stuff all skepticism
and science everything that's kind of
like
oh you're so close-minded it's just it
has a little bit of that kind of thing
yeah you know and a little bit of like
kind of hippy-dippy like
eastern religions are way better kind of
thing
taylor well there's something to be said
for that too because [ __ ] science is
nothing but just a constant series of
corrections
constantly correcting itself it is just
a tool yeah all right
it's wrong it's always wrong because as
time goes on
that it's we find out more find out more
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
in that way it was correct it's just uh
there's not gonna be any way
with the technology you have now to
prove that reincarnation happens or to
prove in these other dimensions
even though science postulates these
other dimensions you know you know
higher dimensions in physics and [ __ ]
like that
it's just that you can't access them
that's mathematical stuff
that they're doing on paper yeah you
can't access it it's another dimension
it's like pointing to a direction that
doesn't exist try it
yeah you can't point to or describing a
color that doesn't right yeah you can't
but maybe on maybe on paper you can do
some math this is
that suggests that there's a bunch of
higher dimensions but i challenge you to
send a probe to a higher dimension and
get some pictures of it
well it's another dimension it's just
outside of our
of our kin of understanding yeah i was
just i was just reminded of when we were
just talking about that i was reminded
that very very funny scene in this
during the courtroom drama thing
where they you know they had their
witnesses come forward and like say all
this stuff about like
reincarnation and whatnot and then the
defense attorney is just kind of like
that's our case like that like we proved
reincarnation yeah yeah yeah
that's funny even though like the the
evidence was a little flimsy i have to
say but you know what i mean it's a
movie
but yeah like i said if you're real if
you haven't seen this one um it does
have kind of a cult following
uh and if you like kind of 70s movies
like i said it's a little odd
uh and it wasn't as scary as i
remembered it being it's really not
scary at all
um but it's really kind of an
interesting like i said it's an
interesting film from the time period a
little it's kind of the
same as some of the ones back then but
it also kind of had its own thing going
on you haven't seen it but you like the
exorcist neoman and this and that
fits right in there yeah you should
definitely see that it's on shutter at
the moment um i think you can probably
see it
it might be on 2b2 now that i'm thinking
about it but yeah adds me a little bit
of altered states in this in a weird way
yeah yeah yeah i see what you're saying
and like i said if you liked the entity
which was
you know the same writer then you would
probably dig this as well it has like a
simple energy
and it has like a similar tonal shift
like in the middle so uh so yeah check
it out like i said it's on shutter
and uh we'll be back next week for
another movie review
and uh we'll see you later bye